im hessischen offenbach am main hat der
zirkus barus seine zelte aufgeschlagen
aber wenn der vorhang aufgeht herrscht
wegen corona nur gähnende leere auf den
zuschauerrängen vorstellungen sind
zurzeit verboten einnahmen für das
familienunternehmen 0 euro und dann gibt
es vor wenigen tagen auch noch einen
echten behörden schock die stadt will
die zirkusleute loswerden wir sollten
anderen tag um 15 uhr weg sein
ich habe gedacht das können wir nicht
wirklich denken oder meinen weil die
dinge dem ganzen prasselte hier steht
wir haben hier über 40 tiere firma
zirkuszelt im räumungsbescheid droht die
stadt knallhart wenn der zirkus
offenbach nicht sofort verlässt kostet
das pro tag 500 euro zwangsgeld das wohl
der tiere sei nicht gewährleistet so die
begründung und dabei war nie ein
mitarbeiter der stadt vor ort um sich
mal ein bild der lage zu machen
was jetzt ich war enttäuscht weil das
ist ja herzlos das ist unmenschlich
viele offenbacher unterstützen den
zirkus helfen mit futterspenden für die
tiere das verhalten ihrer
stadtverwaltung können die bürger nicht
nachvollziehen
ich verstehe dass überhaupt nicht ich
finde das unter aller kanone
aber wie kommt die stadt auf die idee
dem notleidenden zirkus solche knüppel
zwischen die beine zu werfen
zunächst heißt es weil es sich um ein
laufendes verfahren handele können wir
derzeit nicht für interviews zur
verfügung stehen aber nach unserer
anfrage kommt dann doch bewegung in die
sache
nach einem kontrollgang durch das
veterinäramt entscheidet die stadt alles
tipptopp der zirkus da bleiben wir haben
wir sind auch sehr erleichtert
aber da sieht man ja dass das doch ganz
gut war dass man sich gewehrt hat der
zirkus ist erstmal gerettet aber
einnahmen gibt es momentan keine die
artisten sind weiterhin auf spenden
angewiesen damit in der manege nicht
endgültig die lichter ausgehen
[Musik]